anyway that's a different channel all
together sorry sorry so let's talk about
cost of living to stop should we michael
lewis uh the boss of eon he's been
talking about it as you know he says 40
of people could be in fuel poverty by
october george osborne says a windfall
tax is inevitable it is isn't it well we
continue to look at this situation very
very closely i mean the first thing to
say is uh we've put together a package
worth 22 billion pounds so far this year
of which nine billion is targeted
directly at
measures affecting energy and
uh we we recognize that there is a a
real challenge for households up and
down the country which will likely get
worse in the autumn when the uh the next
round of the energy price cap uh kicks
in so yes we do we do we do want to to
make sure that we take the action that
we need what i would say is that we want
to make sure we get the action that we
take right on on the concept of a
windfall tax uh itself
we are very very clear that there is a
real need at a time when the industry is
making very significant profits to see
those profits reinvested in new offshore
installations getting more out of the
north sea at a time which is obviously
vital in terms of energy supply but also
good for jobs and the wider economy if
we do not see that investment
materialized then we are very clear that
all options are on the table
sorry what did it not why would it well
ultimately that's a question for the
industry to answer i was saying they
still would aren't the bp the head of bp
said he still would even if there was a
windfall i was present at a uh summit
that the prime minister held at number
10 a few months ago with the industry
itself we were talking about the
incentives for uh the industry to get
get stuck in in the north sea and to
actually make sure that we get the
capacity that we need to wean us off a
reliance from russian oil and gas and
they were really clear this was a range
of companies small and large not just
the bps of this world but
a whole range of providers and they were
really clear that after such a difficult
few years during a pandemic when of
course their profits absolutely
nosedived that they needed a period
where they could have time to reinvest
if that doesn't happen
now that obviously they are making very
significant profits then all options uh
are on the table here because we've got
to make sure that we we support families
yeah jesse norman a former financial
secretary to the treasury i mean he's
been
tweeting about that very point and he
said do those who oppose a levy think
oil and gas companies should enjoy a
one-way bet in which they benefit from
public support when prices fall but make
no extra contribution when prices rise
well i mean look jesse makes a very
powerful point there and you know we are
certainly not ruling it out i mean what
i would say is obviously i'm not ever
instinctively drawn to
uh to to to increasing taxes insofar as
it risks deterring investment in uh new
capacity and new jobs but look it is it
at least our extraordinary circumstances
we recognize there are extraordinary
pressures on family finances and the
industry needs to hear the message loud
and clear if investment doesn't go in
we can't rule out
73 of those who voted conservative in
2019 support a windfall attacks well i
think the public are absolutely
concerned about the situation that they
can see and you're not there from what
you were saying we're not ruling it out
i mean as i say we're not we're not at
this point making any any announcement
but we are we are definitively nice
well look we have always said to the
industry and this is something which was
communicated loud and clear back earlier
in the spring shortly after the russian
invasion that we need to see
uh the the industry step up to its part
of the bargain and invest in north sea
uh delivery because if that doesn't
happen then they are in effect just
banking the profits and not doing
anything uh to to justify those and
these are
uh effectively as you say off and uh and
and and extraordinary uh extraordinary
gains for the industry so the chance was
very clear we're not philosophically
attracted to this but if the situation
doesn't improve in terms of them
stepping up to the plate uh we can't
rule this out what do you mean by
stepping up to the plate
investing putting in the putting in
putting in these these extra profits to
actually make sure that they are setting
up new fields for offshore if they
didn't do that then you wouldn't be
looking for well i think i think if we
can see that the industry is reinvesting
these profits into the next generation
of nausea oil and gas which is what we
need as a transition fuel both to help
with uh current supply problems but also
crucially to to transition the wider
economy to
zero at the moment given the amount of
they can net
money that they're making well we we
obviously keep that situation under
review we would love to see as i say
these extra profits going into something
really productive and tangible in the
real economy that's what we'd like the
industry to do that's signal uh that we
have hoped to send to the industry and
which they in fairness more or less
committed to when uh they met the prime
minister and the business secretary and
myself uh earlier in the spring so
it is it is a test for the industry does
this does this investment come forward
and if it doesn't uh frankly reflecting
the seriousness of the situation
they can expect the government to have
to look at all our options let's talk
about the long-awaited su grey report
i read in my morning papers that uh a
white hall source is saying sue grey is
playing politics and enjoying the
limelight a little too much um a slur
ahead of her report being uh published
later this week you'd condemn that i'm
sure i i would i mean i think
the one thing i would say about sugra
and i've never met her but
i've heard a great deal about her is
that you know by repute she's one of the
most fiercely independent uh and
professional civil servants in in the
whole of in the whole of government and
brings a vast range of experience to
bear so i don't think there's any
politics there's obviously a range of
questions practical questions involving
doubtless uh discussion with the police
and the civil service authorities about
what
uh what can go into this report and when
it should be
published but in in no way do i think is
there is there anything other than a
practical dimension to the question of
when it comes out now that the police
have concluded their investigation much
made of this meeting between the prime
minister and mrs grey regardless of who
called it i mean who we don't know uh
why on earth would the pm agree to go to
a meeting like this ahead of the report
being published well my understanding uh
is that the meeting was instigated by
doesn't matter that's great but but i
agree i don't think that's i i don't
well it matters only in so far as that
explains that he wasn't the one
instigating it there are as i said there
are lots of practical questions here
which need to be bottomed out in terms
of for example
who can be named uh in in in this report
and uh the extent to which uh
photographic evidence can be included i
think it is it is important that those
practical dimensions are resolved do i
think in any way that the integrity of
this report should be questioned no
because as i say
sue gray has a reputation which dates
back decades in terms of uh her ability
to
make judgments without fear or favor and
i think she will absolutely deliver it
even if it was mrs gray who called the
meeting and she categorically says that
wasn't the case um both sides saying it
wasn't them why would he attend a
meeting when why didn't he just say you
know what let's wait until this meeting
until the report's been published and
then we can talk about it as i say it
would have been in essence to have
received an update and to why then
well on the basis if he were invited to
meet and as i said it it is my
understanding that that that was the
basis but he could have said no he's
surprised i mean ultimately he could
have done but look it's the point here
is i don't think it it would it would in
any way it would have been improper
indeed it would have been somewhat
churlish i think to have declined so you
understand that the optics are not good
when a head of an independent allegedly
independent report she's a civil servant
so how independent is it a report being
published the prime minister has a
private meeting with the person that's
writing the report the civil service is
independent i think it's really
important we we reaffirmed that this
process is is totally independent of
any political
uh pressure and what's her boss
well her boss is so simon case the the
the the cabinet
well ultimately the prime minister's in
charge of the government but the the the
civil service stands apart from the
political structures of government and
ms gray as we've discussed is one of the
uh the most
uh the most respected yeah
i i do not believe in any way
that uh we should we should conflate the
fact that the prime minister obviously
sets atop the whole of government from
the fact the civil service is capable of
standing apart from the political issues
of the day and indeed that's that's how
for example going back to 2010 coalition
negotiations were broken for example
yeah there has to be an element whereby
the civil service and government stand
apart and they do absolutely
but go back to my question which is the
optics you must accept are somewhat
askew by the prime minister i i i really
really don't think so as i say this is
there are lots of genuine practical
issues when publishing a report of this
nature which has
significance not just obviously for the
prime minister himself but crucially for
a whole number of people in downing
street many of whom of course do not
have a voice and a platform you know
very junior civil servants very junior
political staffers the question of
whether any of them are named in this
report the question of what
evidence as i say is included within it
the questions uh you know are not are
not straightforward here and are
genuinely sensitive for people's lives
and careers and
uh public profiles so i think i think it
is it is important to get involved with
that should you if it's an independent
result as i said i do not believe that
this meeting was anything other than a a
discussion of the technicalities of the
process and as i said i think it it it
would be genuinely
wrong uh to to impugn that there has
been any pressure put on the on the
nature of this report in any way and i
believe that when it's published we will
see that this is we will you say the
report could be significant for the
prime minister in what way well
ultimately this is a report which is
hotly anticipated the fact we're talking
about it now shows the profile which is
uh attracted over recently could it put
his position in jeopardy i mean also
ultimately uh my faith in the prime
minister is is is absolute uh we we've
heard from the police last week that
they've concluded their investigations
and the
the the prime minister received a fine
for which he is rightly and i i know
sincerely apologized that was for
one incident of a uh of a
slice of birthday cake between me i
understand but he's overseen she's
overseen
126 people 126 fines have been issued
and and he has taken full responsibility
about the events in in downing street
and
obviously he's set in train a series of
reforms to make sure that
that building is running the most
professional possible fashion
going forward but i think we also need
to to remember without excusing what
happened but by way of context the
extraordinary pressure that that group
of people were under during the the
course of the pandemic and and the fact
that they were not uh you know they were
working the longest imaginable hours
under the most enormous amount of
pressure that in no way diminishes the
seriousness of what happened but it does
provide some context
let me just ask you before i let you go
um 20 monkey pox cases in the uk so far
more to be we're expecting will be told
about later on today how worried is the
government
well as with any uh new disease and
obviously after the cover pandemic
doubly so we we continue to monitor this
very very closely i i think i would say
i'm cautious but i'm certainly not
concerned in in the sense of sort of uh
feeling any
any concern about our ability to handle
this situation crucially there is a
vaccine which is available which works
for monkey parks and
all the evidence is is that it's spread
by physical contact so it's not an error
exactly and that being the case the the
risk of community transmission is much
lower as i said we have a working
vaccine if people present with symptoms
or they have very close contacts then we
are advising that they quarantine for
three weeks but the threshold for that
is is quite high it really does need to
become physical contact or sexual
contact and we're hearing about a baby
in in icu aren't we uh well i i'm not
aware of that case i mean certainly uh
you know we we do urge particular
caution with immunosuppressed with
pregnant women all the groups who are
normally more vulnerable uh and yeah
what i would say is we we're we're
cautious but we're certainly not uh in a
position where i would in any way worry
the public that this is uh some some
repeat of cover because it certainly
does not appear to be in anywhere near
the same uh platform of seriousness we
must let you go minister thank you very
much thank you for taking the time to
join us thanks very much looking at the
front pages of the newspapers this
morning for you let's start with the
daily telegraph claiming that the
cabinet secretary will come under heavy
pressure to resign as the sugray report
is expected to conclude that he bears
ultimate responsibility
daily mail says